I just making me paranoid Andy look at
this guy right here no no it's L down
sir relax doesn't it look like he is
secretly recording here move your hand
oh no he's secretly recording yeah this
television show that's what I'm looking
at right now this man is secretly
recording the show by right and actually
that's how we distribute the show now by
phone you're doing a great job it's much
cheaper than having all these kids yeah
how you doing I'm good how are you I'm
doing really well actually got a sweet
crap we're gonna get some yeah we got
nothing we got a great show tonight yeah
we do excellent program a lot to talk
about I think there's now what is it now
800 over 800 Democratic candidates
leaving the president do you anyone here
could name everyone who's running for
president in the demo for the demo
because I'm sure there's people that we
no one's ever heard of right yeah that
are just running in their own you're our
sound guy declared like five minutes ago
I think some people are starting to
capture people's imaginations you know
yeah we're out there there's a couple of
candidates people are excited about and
then there's some controversies I don't
know if you heard about this but during
a campaign event in Iowa South Bend
mayor Pete Buddha Jed you know this guy
okay he was heckled by an anti-gay
protester yeah yeah boo de jedge handled
it like a pro and said settle down mr.
vice president so looked out
get that on your phone why you do why
did you shove it under your ass that's
just I didn't think you were really
recording the show you can no no no you
can put it back in your pocket I didn't
I didn't mean to frighten you that's it
all right yeah that looks really natural
the way you've got it right now yeah no
this is that's big Pete Buddha jej
officially announced his candidacy this
week a lot of people talking about him
and if he wins Buddha jej would be our
first openly gay president yeah when I
say openly gay I'm talking to you
Millard Fillmore
I'm committing to this joke even though
you don't like it it's all I got
so I'm just doubling down on it see
there was a rumor about Millard Fillmore
Oh Thank You Conan sorry I wasn't sure
what was going on yeah I'm just holding
in case we have to cut that one out
but then again this guy's got it on his
I think there are people in the audience
you think that's someone who's running
now Millard Fillmore there's so many
people anyway speaking of Democratic
candidates in his memoirs presidential
candidate John Hickenlooper heard about
this guy John Hickenlooper gives
detailed accounts of his sexual
conquests yes apparently his signature
move was giving women the old
Hickenlooper
his phone wouldn't record that one